foreign
[Music]
this is StarTalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist today's topic is nuclear
winter
you might have remember that from some
decades ago Old Timers would that came
out and it changed geopolitics people
realizing that not only are there no
winners in a nuclear exchange and maybe
all of life on Earth would be rendered
extinct
why are we talking about that because
the future of Life Institute gives an
annual award to people who by their
actions or by their influence have
managed to preserve civilization in ways
that people might not have known either
at the time like before or after
a guy with me Chuck Nice to help me do
this Chuck how you doing man hey Neil
how are you yeah good good we have on
today's program two of this year's
recipients of that award for their
participation in the nuclear winter
project we first have Professor Brian
tune who we're going to get to in our
second segment he is a former student of
Carl Sagan's and was one of the
co-authors on the original nuclear
winter paper
we also have who will be accepting the
award on behalf of Carl Sagan Carl
Sagan's Widow and long time collaborator
andrewian and welcome back to StarTalk
it's great to be back with you Neil yeah
so let me go chat too yeah now let me
tell you Neil and just became my
favorite guest of all time okay
that was easy yeah because no because
you you know I'm I'm not here to be
acknowledged but I okay there's still a
low bar
so so the reason for this occasion is
the future of Life Institute gives an
award every year to people who mattered
in the preservation of civilization and
often there they did something that
maybe you didn't know about or if you
did did you know how significant it was
and this year's award goes in part to
Carl Sagan and because Sagan has not
been with us he's died back in 96 or 97
it was and so 96 thank you and so and
you will be receiving this award on his
behalf you are a 35-year collaborator of
Carl Sagan and his widow and but you
were you were there in the middle of all
this publishing books with him
co-producing Cosmos with him the
original one from 1980 and uh you you
won an Emmy Award a Peabody Award which
is my favorite of all the awards out
there is the Peabody because that one
really shows you care about the world
and it's not just were you popular but
did you have a message that mattered and
you're also a writer director producer
and uh those who didn't know the famous
Voyager record the interstellar message
that is still on its way out into
Interstellar space
Anne was a creative director of that and
so and you're like you're the right
person to have to begin this
conversation about what was going on in
the early 1980s with this whole notion
of nuclear winter because I know you you
were Carl's most trusted collaborator on
all fronts and so what was going on back
then
and I fear that nuclear winter could be
all the rage now too because of the
instability
of
Human Social organization and of course
because of the flirting with nuclear war
that that Putin has done recently yeah
but back in the 1980s
there were some 60 000 nuclear weapons
on hair triggers
around the Earth
it was the kind of Epic hostage drama
in which everyone on Earth was held
hostage to a nuclear arms race that was
out of control
and to the fact that the superpowers
were engaged
and ratcheting up technologically as
well as numerically of nuclear weapons
just to remind people back then there
were only two superpowers the United
States and the Soviet Union today we
might think of China as one but
definitely not back then but China
it was a uh you know had some nuclear
weapons player in the game and yeah I'm
sorry I said they were a player in the
game they're playing the game you're
definitely a player uh as well as a
number of other countries
so while we were already deeply
concerned and Carl was
spreading the alarm about climate change
even back then
at the time because we hadn't begun to
see so palpably the effects of climate
change that we see now
the danger of nuclear war was a great
Shadow on our future
and uh
there was research
being done and your next guest will
speak to it far more knowledgeably than
I can
uh modeling with
what we would consider now primitive uh
computer
uh capabilities
the effects of what a nuclear war would
be there had been studies of the
volcanic effects
uh for instance
the effects of the tembora volcano in
1816 which was also called
1800 and almost freeze to death because
of The Long Winter then and so they were
intimations to scientists named krutson
and Burks had done some research in this
area there were intimations that there
would be unforeseen consequences of a
nuclear exchange not just you know the
immolation of millions and the burning
of cities and the horrendous nightmarish
scenarios that were already known
but then also the long-term consequences
and of course Neil you said uh that I'm
accepting this on Carl's behalf I am
deeply honored to be doing that but
you know my role in nuclear winter was
that it unfolded in my living room
and while we did collaborate on so much
uh this was uh really a collaboration
between uh Turco tune Ackerman Pollock
and Carl Sagan and all credit goes to
them
for the science
and especially I think to Carl in the
area
of educating the public
on this unforeseen danger which of
course at the time
um the defense industry and uh
political establishment had little
interest in promulgating this
information to the public because it
really made them look so bad they had
spent trillions
on weapons of mass destruction and
hardly anything
on researching the consequences of their
extravagant foolhardiness
and so
it's against that backdrop an
intransigent Ronald Reagan
um who felt that Star Wars defense
system uh you know Shields could protect
us from incoming nuclear weapons and an
unwillingness to deal with this evil
empire uh that he saw as he saw the
Soviet Union and so against this
backdrop
nuclear winter unfolds in the scientific
community
so Anne I'm just wondering in the
original 1980 Cosmos
um were there any tap Roots there that
you think would have sensitized you and
Carl to sort of rising trying to rise up
to make this message known oh absolutely
Neil I'm so glad you mentioned that
because
just to put time in context here you
would have been working on the 1980
Cosmos in like 1979 or 1978 and the
nuclear winter paper came out a little
deeper into the 80s so this is
83. so this this predates it by a few
years so yeah what do you have to say
there
that colleagues and friends of his
including Jim Hansen were doing Roger
Ravel we're doing on this fledgling
climate science this area of climate
science just to be clear Jim Hansen we
know him in Star talk and you're saying
he was at it 40 years ago I believe
that's correct oh my gosh I think that's
true yeah and very courageous and took a
lot of heat
uh because of it as did Carl
um because you mentioned Cosmos the
original cosmo series in 19 it was
broadcast in 1980. so in that series
there was episode four which was called
Heaven and Hell
and it was a contrast between the planet
Earth
and a sister planet Venus and Carl had
done his PhD thesis in I think 1961
on the runaway greenhouse effect on
Venus he was in fact the first person I
believe to know the actual temperature
of Venus and to understand
what had turned Venus from
possibly a clement world we don't know
that for sure yet but possibly Clement
or certainly more Clement than it is now
to uh an inferno a hellish Inferno and
and that the thinking for that Venus is
the same size as Earth and the same
surface gravity and it's a you know it's
near us in orbit around the Sun so and
there it is this hellish fire oh my gosh
yeah not to mention they also had
venusian Exxon let's not remember let's
yes well I'm not so sure about that
Chuck but
but so so we were very conscious of what
we were doing to and we said so in
Cosmos with Steven Soder our co-writer
um we were very conscious of what we
were doing to the earth atmosphere
and that we were inadvertently altering
the climate of this planet which was
especially heartbreaking because if we
hadn't been pumping all this carbon
dioxide and other greenhouse gases into
the atmosphere
the scientific forecast for the planet
was great climate for the next 50
000 years
and so here was this paradise that we
evolved
to be happiest on of all the worlds in
the universe
and yet here we were mindlessly
thoughtlessly
um ruining this planet for our
civilization and you know you mentioned
the future of life
award which is the occasion for for this
this delightful conversation with you
guys and um
you know
I don't think there was ever a person or
to my knowledge there has never been
anyone
who took so to Heart
our responsibility to protect the future
of life as did Carl Sagan and so
um just to tie it up I'm really thrilled
that he is getting this award I think
it's wonderful and very just and anyone
who's seen any of the cosmoses
uh no one is saying okay I have to sit
through a documentary again the word
documentary isn't even in the
conversation because Cosmos sits
separate and apart from every other
attempt
of science professionals and Educators
to communicate science what is the
secret sauce that distinguishes Cosmos
from all other documentaries we've ever
seen
well the point always was from the
beginning for me
as a non-scientist as someone who was
told by a science Professor that I was
inedible
someone who felt very much excluded from
science
alienated from science
was as an outsider it always seemed to
me and
and luckily I was working with someone
who was an Insider but who also
two insiders Carl and Steve who who also
understood and felt
the power of the scientific perspective
as a transforming
emotional spiritual experience
be completely cold and dispassionate as
you gather the evidence analyze it
create your hypothesis no emotion in any
of that
but once you have some findings
some tiny
incomplete
insights into how
nature is put together
feel it
take it within take it to heart and I
think that's the big danger
about the future of our lives and our
children and grandchildren
is that if we keep this concept of
science as a jumble of amazing facts
that are somehow external to us
and don't take it too hard as deeply
as the most spiritual
feelings we've ever had in our lives
then we are doomed
because it's not separate it's the story
of us and everything that we value and
love only it's a more disciplined
approach
trying to find out a little bit of Truth
not any absolute truth and just finally
I mean this is my passion you can't top
that Anne you can't go on like that and
in conclusion no ad come on and I say
this as someone who's earned these
feelings as an outsider as a person who
has no credentials but has really just
had great teachers who have opened this
way for me and that is you know what
whatever you feel and think it's I'm all
for it I don't want to take that away
from anybody but for me personally
the most soaring spiritual experiences
of my life
have been this kind of way of loving
nature which is to look at nature
not with your projections and your fears
and your fantasies
but to be as cold-eyed and as real as
you possibly can be in order to know it
and still
love what you see
well I'm sure that person who told you
you were ineligible uh they're
short-sighted rudeness they're certainly
choking on it right now aren't they well
I think he's probably dead okay
and once again you'll win
absolutely I know I've been very lucky
so lucky we're going to take a break
when we come back we're going to bring
in Professor Brian tune when we come
back
hey there we wanted to take this break
to congratulate the winners of this
year's future of Life award by
catalyzing developing and popularizing
the science of nuclear winter they've
made it less likely that will actually
cause a nuclear winter the winters are
John Burks Paul krutson Jeannie Peterson
Alan Roebuck Carl Sagan Georgie
stencikov Brian tune and Richard Turco
congratulations and thank you for making
us both more scared and more safe
we're back Star Talk I got with me Chuck
Nice and the topic today is nuclear
winter and not only that the future of
Life award is something given annually
to people who had something to do with
protecting civilization and we have in
this segment Professor Brian tune uh
Brian was a co-author with Carl Sagan in
a research paper in the 1980s
highlighting nuclear winter what it
means and why it is important not only
scientifically but geopolitically so
Brian welcome to StarTalk thank you Emil
as a as a cold war baby I as am I anyone
in this call is uh we we kind of knew
nuclear war was bad okay and made it
clear yeah you you you're immolated if
you're in ground zero where the bomb
strikes and all your buildings are
leveled so this is kind of well known or
or at least well feared and now you came
up with another reason to fear nuclear
exchange so how does tell me exactly how
nuclear winter works
well let me tell you how we discovered
it in the first place and so what
happened uh at the time I worked for
NASA
and we were studying things like
um how volcanic eruptions could change
the climate which was partly triggered
by Carl's interest in the wave of
darkening on Mars which people thought
might be a vegetation advancing over the
margin service but really he thought
well more likely dust storms
so that got me into studying dust of the
atmosphere which people thought could
come from volcanoes which turned out not
to be right either it turned out early
sulfuric acid is what they put in the
atmosphere
anyway in about 1980 I was studying
volcanic eruptions and the climate of
the earth uh supersonic transports their
effect on that earth's climate and other
kinds this is the commercial airplane
the SST right exactly transport yeah
yeah exactly and we had thought about
nuclear weapons and hadn't really
thought of any way they could do
anything terrible to The Climate but
then the Alvarez group at Berkeley
discovered that an asteroid had hit the
earth 66 million years ago
and uh Kill the Dinosaurs
and so we started thinking oh wow how
did that happen and uh we concluded well
this is because of the debris in the
atmosphere from the impact well but just
to be clear an asteroid hitting the
Earth kills any dinosaur where the
crater is but this one killed all the
dinosaurs on all of the earth so that
was the big conundrum here right how do
you kill everything if the if the impact
is local to some region okay go on and
killed about 75 percent of the species
on the planet
and not just the dinosaurs so in any
rate
um I gave a talk about this early on
because there was huge skepticism about
this idea a geologist said no no this
violates all the tenets of geology
nothing catastrophic ever happened it's
all just a Continuum and actually
asteroids fit into that Continuum
because the moon formed from an asteroid
impact on the earth about the asteroids
about as big as Mars and there's been
constant collisions we had one a few
years ago and over Russia that that was
quite large and her thousand people or
more so it is a Continuum but
nevertheless people were skeptical of
that and so I evaluated how the
dinosaurs might have been killed by that
and someone said oh what about nuclear
Wars and so we went back and I called up
Richard Turco who I knew worked for a
company that knew something about
nuclear weapons and I said well maybe we
should look into this
so he and I started doing some
calculations of dust in the atmosphere
and said wow that could actually do
something bad
and uh then kutson and Burks thought
about forest fires being started by a
nuclear war and you know rich said no no
that's not it it's cities are a set of
fire you have a big nuclear explosion
and you'll set the city on fire and this
is what happened in Hiroshima
in Nagasaki and Hiroshima there was a
firestorm that started a few hours after
the nuclear explosion it released a
thousand times as much energy as a
nuclear explosion to burn all that
material
and It produced a plume of smoke that
rose up into the stratosphere
and so we realized from that that you
burn all these cities around the world
you're going to put Smoke on the
atmosphere
and smoke is very absorbing you know
anybody who's looked at their fireplace
knows there's all this black junk all
over it it's called black carbon and it
absorbs sunlight very well and so we did
these calculations and found that the
sunlight would be diminished at the
surface of the Earth
now we think it would be so dark at the
surface of the Earth
that'd be like a moonless night
human beings would barely in broad
daylight would be like a a moonless
night that's right okay middle of the
day it would look like a moonless night
and because of that it's just like every
other night the temperatures start
dropping it's just like winter you don't
you let the light go down for a long
time the temperatures keep dropping and
so we found that you'd have sub freezing
temperatures in the Continental areas
all over the all over the Earth and when
we found this we knew Carl was
interested in this problem and Jim
pawlik and I were both students of curl
and so we called up Carl and said you
know hey Carl you want to want to work
on this problem with this
you know Carl's interest came from a
different place which is very
interesting Carl was trying to figure
out how many civilizations there were in
the in the Galaxy we live in
and uh he calculated how many stars
there were and how many planets around
the stars and so on and so forth and at
that time all those things are guesses
now we know how many planets that rubber
around the average star he gets pretty
well and so we're pretty far down in
that chain of the Drake equation trying
to figure out how many civilizations
there are and the answer is a lot and
Carl was really bothered by that he said
well where are they why aren't we
communicating with them why aren't they
visiting us
and um he concluded the answer was it
because they destroyed themselves
very quickly as soon as they developed
the understanding of atoms and the
energy that's in Mass they would start
fighting amongst themselves and destroy
their civilizations and he was concerned
that that would um
the fate of the Earth would be and so to
Carl and he has a famous quote that it
would be Elementary planetary hygiene to
get rid of nuclear weapons
so Carl came in from a different
direction than the rest of us
plus he already had a following so if he
gets to speak on this on his platforms
this could work its way into geopolitics
in every way that it should because we
know none of those folks are reading the
journals that you're publishing in
absolutely so Carl played a critical
role in this
you know I he was fairly aware of the
science he understood the science from
his work on Venus and other problems and
he'd work with us on other issues like
the volcano problem so Carl understood
the science behind this but his major
role was to communicate this idea the
danger of these weapons you know I have
to say I to me this was just a science
problem you know I was young at the time
I didn't anticipate the political
aspects of this so I was kind of
surprised at the huge interest in it
um and I'm likewise surprise nowadays
and in the last 10 or 15 years or we've
shown for example that a war between
India and Pakistan could kill billions
of people by this that politicians just
showed no interest in that
so we really need a curl and the modern
day to try to wake people up to this
problem
um but Roberts I think we're missing an
important Link in this chain here we
already know nuclear in exchange of
nuclear weapons is bad so why would this
get any special attention Beyond just
saying the cities will burn
how did it work its way into the
geopolitics of the day
so what happens when you burn all these
cities it's just what happened after
Hiroshima is that the smoke from the
burning City reaches the stratosphere
you know this matters because if you put
stuff in the stratosphere there's no
rain there so it's not washed out
quickly you know stuff stays in the
upper atmosphere for years before it's
finally removed I got to add something
so what we're saying there is when you
get particles in the lower atmosphere
raindrops nucleate on them and then the
Raindrop takes it out clearing the air
but you're saying the stratosphere is
too high for that to happen and once
it's up there it has a very long
lifetime absolutely and so we've seen
this in the modern day you know I live
in Colorado downwind of California it's
choking here
Summers all that smoke
but that's you know only a couple of
days old and it gets washed out yeah it
doesn't pollute Washington DC
unfortunately
um but you put it in a Stratosphere
we've also seen this happen twice in the
last two years never have we seen this
before but 2017 there was a fire in
British Columbia that smoke in the
stratosphere we could see it for almost
a year and in 2020 in the New Year's
there were big fires in Australia they
also put smoke in the stratosphere we
could see that from satellites for more
than a year and we could see not only
that but the smoke Rose the sun heated
it made it warm and it Rose to high
altitude 20 or 30 kilometers and then
our models of nuclear winter it Rose to
80 kilometers which is way up in the
upper atmosphere
so the smoke sits there it stays here
for a long time and of course these
forest fires that we saw in the last few
years that isn't very much smoke
whereas you burn all the cities of the
Earth or the ones in Europe and the
United States and Russia it's a huge
amount of smoke
and that smoke absorbs sunlight and
prevents it from reaching the surface so
which which work informed
um the other more because you're looking
at the dinosaurs and their nuclear
winter and that you're looking at an
actual you know our our own
self-destruction so which which came
first were you saying like oh now we
look you know we had Hiroshima so we can
look back and say see we're right about
the dinosaurs or was it the dinosaur
modeling that said see this is what's
going to happen with the nuclear uh
attacks that we'll have
well with the dinosaurs
there is a layer in Colorado you can go
down and touch it if you happen to be in
Southern Colorado left from this
asteroid collision and there's full of
asteroid debris but it's also a full of
smoke there's 66 million year old smoke
there
and in order to get that much smoke you
had to burn everything on the surface of
the Earth all the trees all the grasses
and even some of it probably that was
subsurface
so the dinosaur is probably largely
perished in the fire and the glowing
Skies from the infalling asteroidal
debris but in the oceans it was Pitch
Black the Plankton couldn't reproduce
and so the oceanic extinctions were
caused by the light going away and of
course it got very cold there also so if
any dinosaurs survived the initial fires
they would have died in the cold
and so that's a strong parallel with
what happens after a nuclear war so at
the end of the day you don't simply
destroy your enemy you destroy all of
the earth everything so that's so that's
that's the takeaway here that's the
takeaway is if you start a nuclear war
not only do you kill your own people but
you kill everybody on the planet
as I we studied a war between India and
Pakistan which were threatening each
other with nuclear weapons frequently we
thought 50 to 100 million people there
would die from the initial blast but now
we think that the 100 or a billion to
two billion people around the world
would die if there were a war between
India and Pakistan because of all this
smoke in the stratosphere blocking
sunlight
and we think if there were a war between
NATO the U.S Russia probably 5 billion
people would die and the reason for that
is that with no sunlight the
temperatures fall we've looked at say
Iowa and the Ukraine which are two major
bread baskets it quickly Falls below
freezing there even in the summer
every day the mean low temperature is
below freezing for several years you're
not going to grow anything at middle
attitudes
by mean low temperature you mean the
average low temperature right yes
emotional state of the temperature
well it is
so personal right that's so mean that's
some mean temperatures yeah probably
feel that way so we've looked at the
agricultural response to this and it's
devastating
across the Earth we've actually looked
at every plant every country now in the
earth some countries are very sensitive
to this like Russia Russia would lose
most of its population
starvation in a case like this and so
with the United States and Canada High
latitude countries just couldn't Farm in
these circumstances there'd still be
some some ability to farm in the tropics
because it didn't quite so cold
uh well uh Brian I I hate to be a uh
self-serving self-centered person but is
there a place on Earth where your models
say that one might be okay well New
Zealand and Australia
um because they raise a lot of sheep
which they export and so if they stopped
exporting their sheep who live on grass
they could eat the sheep and probably
not be calorie deficient but the rest of
way longer than everybody else yes and
people don't realize how vulnerable the
Earth is you know people have heard the
story uh in the Bible and in the Quran
it's in both books about Joseph
advising the Pharaoh about bad weather
the pharaoh's dreaming of cows and these
seven fat cows and seven skinny cows
yeah exactly and so Joseph says it's
gonna be seven good years store up grain
and you can feed the Egyptians for then
seven years afterwards and the Pharaoh
does this got a longer term than the
president and a big hero after 14 years
but that isn't the real world the real
world there's only 60 days about two
months of grain and Storage
you shut you have a global catastrophe
from an asteroid impact from a large
volcanic eruption from a nuclear war
agriculture is going to shut off
there's about enough food in a city for
a week that's it you got to bring in
more food now there's only enough food
around the around the earth for 60 days
after that mass starvation was going to
occur and there's not much you can do
about it there's people thinking about
well maybe we could raise mushrooms
maybe we could Harvest kelp well yeah
sure we could if we had time to think
about it but you're only going to have
60 days to respond and if it's a global
nuclear war there's no more oil
refineries there's no more
transportation that you know most of the
science people in the country trying to
figure out how to survive themselves the
agricultural people don't have any fuel
anymore you know you're not you're not
going to quickly solve this problem by
doing something different than what
you've been doing well I am moving to
New Zealand and stocking up on shiitakes
so we're going to take a break when we
come back we're going to bring Andrea
back into the conversation and we just
want to sort of explore the geopolitics
of the day what was the reaction from
people from fellow scientists from
politicians and just to ask ourselves
how close were we to this catastrophe on
start talk
we're back on Star Talk about nuclear
winter why because the future of Life
award is going to people who had
something to do with first figuring it
out it was real a real thing to worry
about and having the world know about it
we've got here Brian toon who is one of
the co-authors on the original paper for
this and we're having we have andrewian
who will be accepting the future of Life
award on behalf of Carl Sagan her
longtime lifetime collaborator uh let me
just ask both of you could you comment
what was the the initial reaction was it
one of disbelief uh maybe we can start
with the public and and and the co and
Carl's colleagues and uh you you saw
this firsthand right
I did and what happened was coinciding
with the publication of the scientific
paper that Brian and Carl and their
colleagues published I think it was was
it in science or nature Brian I'm trying
to remember which one in science in
science
um
Carl published an article in Parade
Magazine
which was a Sunday supplement in a
pre-online world which got to 70 million
people in the United States
uh and so this was a an article written
for the public
and it was revealing uh heretofore
unsuspected
consequence of nuclear war
and so
because parade at that time was so
tremendously influential and the reason
that Carl and later and together we
wrote for Parade Magazine was because it
was penetration to the readership that
was not reading Scientific American or
any of the excellent uh public science
communication
Publications it was for everyone
and in the plainest and most uh
you know as always Carl tremendously
eloquent
it described this consequence that Brian
and Carl and their colleagues had
discovered and the impact was enormous
you know it's been a while since I went
through the papers of that moment and so
my impression is a bit anecdotal but
Carl was on the big TV shows of the time
which again in a pre-online culture were
tremendously influential like Nightline
in which I think he was on 10 or 20 of
such programs in a very short space of
time
again in the most crystalline possible
language explaining the these
consequences
and I can talk personally about one
perhaps the most impactful reaction to
nuclear winter and that is that Carl was
asked to brief the pope so we went to
the Vatican he was asked to brief the
Central Committee of what was then the
Soviet Union the governing body
where all the power was
uh in the former Soviet Union
and
Gorbachev was the premier then prime
minister and
when it was over we were told later the
first human ever to walk in space a
cosmonaut named Alexa leonov
said that he had been a member of the
Central Committee when Carl presented
the nuclear winter thesis and after Carl
left the room
lay an upset publicly that one of the
members of a Central Committee
turned to everyone else and said well
it's over now isn't it
and he was talking of course about the
constantly ratcheting up nuclear arms
race
and that is in the midst of Gorbachev
making a tremendous effort with Ronald
Reagan
trying everything he could think of
to including by the way a unilateral
test band on nuclear weapons that the
Russians did and the United States under
Reagan refused to join and that led to
us being arrested three times at the
Nevada nuclear test site
um inspired in fact by this unilateral
Test Ban by the Russians and
when I was told by another uh by a
member of the administration that when
Gorbachev came to the White House
to see uh Reagan he was carrying with
him a copy of Carl's article which had
been published in parade again to a vast
audience and in Russian simultaneously
called together to Mars
and he was brandishing a copy of this to
show Reagan and uh
was summarily rebuffed
because what Carl was thinking at that
time was if we could become involved in
a joint venture which would Channel all
of that testosterone that went into
these wars and and create a kind of an
adventure that Russians and Americans
could watch from home and could
participate in uh in a epic Mission to
Mars that there would be a way to work
out what seemed like these intractable
issues
uh
um and uh unfortunately Reagan was not
at all interested in that
so here we are
right so so Brian what was the
scientific reaction to these results was
there criticism was there praise
well it was rather
mixed there was initially a group of
people
who made comments in the press and had
never even read the paper one of whom
was the editor of nature magazine and he
and Carl got into a quite a dispute over
his kindness since he was
running the theory down and hadn't even
read the paper there are other people
like Freeman Dyson who was a notable
physicist lots of interesting ideas who
likewise said stupid things about it
having never read the paper either
and so there was a reaction like that
and this is part of a continuing thing
where started during the days of the
tobacco problems whereas a whole group
of people telling you people cigarettes
were good for you the same group of
people did everything they could to try
to make nuclear winter look like there
was a problem with it and then they
tried to make global warming look like
there was a problem with it you know
there's the same group of people as
books written about the merchants of
doubt
so there there was a big thing like that
I think Carl and the rest of us were all
called Communists in the Wall Street
Journal and Dukes of the Communists but
nevertheless most of the science
Community saw this like a science
problem they set to work to find
anything wrong with it that they could
there's quite a few people who worked on
it but it was blocked at the time by the
government and so
um in NASA I was told I was going to be
fired and everybody in my building would
be fired if I didn't stop working on
this
and uh and we were told we we tried to
present a paper about it and we were
forced to withdraw that paper because it
hadn't been reviewed
and uh so that was a really important
decision that NASA the local NASA made
to say in the paper hadn't been reviewed
because Carl took that as an opportunity
to review it and so what he did was he
sent a copy of the paper and I draft
paper around everybody in the world
including to Russian scientists who
immediately reproduced the results with
their own models which are even better
than other models at the time and again
as Ann said with very primitive
Computing compared to today exactly
right I mean that's that was you did 40
years ago yeah with an iPhone
at any rate uh
you know so a couple of hundred
scientists got together at a meeting in
Boston I believe in October so I recall
and uh debated the science of the
problem and you know those people did
have uh continuing interest in it and
there were like two people in the
National Science Foundation who were
allowed to work on a defend car there
are some people from the Department of
energy with that time collaborated with
other people and card National Center
for atmospheric research that's correct
that's correct but most of the other
agencies including NASA the science
people told you can't work on this nor
forbid anybody and Noah from working on
it so this is an interesting uh
censorship of science at the time which
I've never seen happen in the other
issue but that doesn't bode well for
science I mean did this last a short
amount of time was it did it drag on
what did it take
for people to come around
it's still going on
there's no how is this still going on
yeah yeah if I may speak to this uh just
several years ago I want to say about
four or five years ago there was what I
consider to be a scurrilous article in
the New Yorker of all places
which was called
something to the effect of nuclear
autumn
and what really shocked me because the
New Yorker has always had such a glowing
reputation for fact checking
was this uncritically
reported uh nuclear Autumn uh really
nothing more than really a comment not a
scientific paper made by a scientist
named Steve Schneider many many years
before
and the person who wrote this article
and the staff of the New Yorker
uncritically published this article
which which said you know that Carl
Sagan had made poor choices and that
this Theory had turned out to be just
and you know not a big effect not a
significant effect at all
and it was absolutely horrifying first
of all because there have been
Publications in the last 10 years in you
know these same scientific journals that
we've been talking about uh by Alan
robach and others saying that you know
with a greater computer
capabilities
the results are every bit as robust as
the original scientists of the Taps
paper
publish and if anything more robust and
so you know it really hasn't stopped and
again it's just this casual smirky
casting of Doubt without anyone doing
the absolutely critical homework uh to
know what's true so may I ask of all
three of you because first of all
I hate to say this but I'm terrified
right now because you know when you look
at what Brian is talking about which is
the story of the dinosaurs and how it
directly mimics and mirrors uh the story
of our own destruction if we so decide
to walk that path
um and then you think about the people
who are naysayers it seems to me like
there needs to be some kind of
Storytelling that happens to get us back
in re-engaged with this and you know
Neil is an incredible communicator and
Cosmos I mean everybody watches all of
them still to this day because it tells
a story you know and Brian and Brian
just told the story of the dinosaurs
that is you know truly compelling what
do we have to do to kind of get people
to feel like I feel right now I can I
can tell you this that my profession or
science in general does not reward
storytellers there's no mechanism to
promote the communication of Science in
fact I I and could you could take this
over in two sentences when I'm done here
just uh whatever the time that I spend
communicating with anybody
is
is at best neutral to my professional
standing that's at best because there's
always somebody say well he should be in
the lab or he should be in this and he
should be there and and this is this is
called Satan's whole life right
absolutely and I know that if it were
possible for him to decide you know to
do it all over again
um he would have done exactly what he
did he followed his Bliss and he felt
that this knowledge was such a precious
and thrilling and emotionally and
spiritually uplifting understanding of
nature that how could you not share it
with everyone he used to say famously
when you're in love you want to tell the
world and that's how he felt he worried
about the future of a society that
aspires to be a democracy such as we
have
if so few of us have the critical
faculties
the ability to know when we're being
manipulated or lied to
the inability to search more deeply to
find out what is real
and of course he wrote about that in the
demon Haunted World and now you see it
you know on Instagram and online every
single day These Warnings these
Prophecies of what happens in a society
based on science and high technology in
which most of us are excluded from it
yeah it's it's just it's a sad State of
Affairs I mean we we can lament what the
world is like today but then I I wonder
to myself how much worse it would have
been had it not been for college and you
know I I hate thinking that way because
every so much still looks so bad today
yeah and and Brian are very disappointed
to learn that there's still this
resistance to that cause what we do know
is that the future of Life award
um is going to both of you and on behalf
of Carl and uh we're I I I'm delighted
by virtue of this program to participate
in the publicity of what that award
means why it was created what it's for
and and why such an award should
continue forever because there are
always such people in some cases behind
the scenes in some cases in front who
are really just trying to make a better
world here and let me ask you and we
don't have a couple of minutes left do
you think this nuclear winter scenario
hastened the the end of the Cold War do
you think it played a role well I'm not
sure sure it's over no okay
I mean I think it may have hastened you
know a kind of a little bit of a change
but of course there were so many other
factors
uh too many variables too many other
very significant factors to say whether
or not it did I think it did
I think it led to a change of attitude
in the Kremlin I'll say that
um because I did see that but I think
there's clear evidence there's clear
evidence that this mattered as uh there
was uh the intermediate range nuclear
forces treaty in 1986 between Ronald
Reagan and Gorbachev which basically
tried to get rid of the missiles in
Europe and it started to build out of
nuclear weapons it's continued to this
day every American president every
Russian president since then has reduced
arsenals although there's still plenty
of them because of nuclear winter and at
the time just before this thing Ronald
Reagan
gave a quote to the New York Times in
which he explained about the year
without a summer and how nuclear winter
worked and said the scientists are
warning us of this that this could
happen and he believed that and he was
going to do something about it and
Gorbachev okay so Carl did get through
to Reagan that's what it sounds like
Gorbachev also after the fact I gave a
similar quote saying and this is
important Russian and American
scientists so this goes back to Carl's
review we got the Russian scientists to
do the same thing in Gorbachev said
Russian and American scientists are
telling us that no one can win a nuclear
war and people of High morals must do
something about this and so he agreed
with Reagan to do something so I think
there was an effect there
and on world policy it's lasted since
that time of course Trump walked away
from this
agreement a few years ago but
nevertheless and I think Carl definitely
was the person that communicated that
information to Reagan and Gorbachev and
other people in the
political establishments that did
something okay so I guess my point then
is the you know if you read the history
books there's no mention of it they talk
about glasnose and they talk about all
these other things they talk about the
collapse of the economy and it seems
like they're missing a very important
Cog in this wheel that that got turned
uh that to bring all of that to an end
or at least to bring leaders to a new
level of sensibility in decisions they
might make
yeah the Soviet Union ended in 1992 you
know so it was about six years after we
started building down these weapons and
so I think the building of weapons is
what triggered it but you know as Ann
just said there are lots of other things
happening there was
very costly to keep building these
weapons and other things which brings me
to a point I think it's important to
know about the present day which is that
Reagan or not Reagan but the United
States and Russia are both
building new weapons of mass destruction
this is partly coming out of the Obama
Administration which in order to get an
agreement on limiting weapons agreed to
give the Department of Defense hundreds
of billions of dollars to build new
weapons so now we're entering an era
where we have Hypersonic gliders we have
drone submarines that are both built by
the Russians who want to reduce the
warning time pretty soon we're going to
have computers deciding whether or not
there's been a launch and we should
launch our missiles because a war has
started okay so we're dropping the level
of nukes but increasing other lethal
weapons of different kinds of well we
have plenty of tactics we have plenty of
nukes left the United States and Russia
between something like 8 000 nuclear
weapons left there's 500 cities in the
United States and Russia five 100 cities
8 000 weapons
that's you know enough weapons to attack
every city that's called Overkill yes
but the problem is that we're advancing
to the state where human beings are not
going to be able to control the weapons
because the warning times are too short
and my computer doesn't work that well I
don't know about yours well I sure will
want to trust those things to decide for
me that we're going to kill everybody on
the planet and I I don't know if you
have enough time for this but there's a
what's
so disturbing is that even when we were
terrified of nuclear war back in the day
there were client State Wars going on
but not a hot war in Europe
and not a hot war in Europe conducted by
a society which in which there is
virtually one decision maker who is
dealing with a rapidly declining economy
rapidly uh loss of status
a country that now has been effectively
uh completely made a pariah state by
virtue of its own actions of invading a
friendly neighbor
and so uh you know I really worry about
nuclear winter I think
virtually as much as I did back then
because the instability I think is
greater now in some ways
well let me ask we got to land This
Plane Brian do you have a social media
footprint that you might share with us
are you are you on on social media
I gave a
Ted Talk a few years ago I will look for
that yeah what's the title of that talk
uh I've been studying nuclear Wars for
35 years and you should be worried okay
an interesting part of that
about six months ago there were four
million views of this
the last time I looked there are eight
million views of this wow so Ann uh
where can we find your your handiwork
I'm
I I think that Carl is more revered more
beloved uh and a greater influence in
many ways than ever before and uh what a
tribute to a man who's been gone for 25
years that I think more people around
the world
are really beginning to get what he was
teaching all along and by the way
whatever were the was the early
resistance from NASA to these ideas let
me remind the public or alert them for
the first time that NASA has a
fellowship in the name of Carl Sagan for
students to study planetary science so I
don't know if that fully makes up for
this but it's certainly some admission
or confession that Carl was on to
something all along uh and I want you to
take us out
with a positive thought
I know
I know you're capable of this but please
please
yes and my hope is based on the fact
that all of us are communicating at the
speed of light right now with people all
around our planet there is a coalescing
community of people who have access to
more information than at any other time
in the history of the world science math
literature history it's all there for
you and
I believe that if we're gonna get make
our way out of this mess it's going to
be with that coalescing community of
people who care about the future of life
and the uh the state of this gorgeous
pale blue dot
and you never you never fail to remind
me why I persistently think of you as
one of the most enlightened people I've
ever met
this has been Star Talk nuclear winter
Edition uh thank you Professor Brian
tune thank you Annie uh it's it's been a
delight to have you back on Star Talk oh
and Chuck
it's okay I'm filled with hope now too
and no no we're good we're good we're
good with chat I'm also buying property
in New Zealand there there you go all
right this has been start talk and I've
been your host Neil deGrasse Tyson as
always I bid you to keep looking up
[Music]